ont tenté de se lever contre ce
coup de force, comme nous le dit
Laurence Martin.
- C'est la riposte
que tout le monde attendait.
En début d'après-midi
à Washington, Joe Biden a
indiqué qu'il n'était
pas dupe des agissements
de Vladimir Poutinmir Poutinmir.
Et que pour lui,
la reconnaissance de régions
séparatistes de Donetsk et
de Louhansk par Moscou
signifiait le début d'une
invasion russe en Ukraine.
Malgré l'escalade, Joe Biden
répète qu'il n'a nullement
l'intention d'envoyer
des troupes sur le terrain.
Il annonce tout de même
des sanctions.
Entre autres, contre
des institutions financières
et des élites russes.
Quelques heures plus tard,
à Ottawa, Justin Trudeau an
des mesures similaires.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- On va imposer des sanctions
supplémentaires contre
les banques russes soutenues
par l'État, et interdire
toute transaction
financière avec elles.
- Le gouvernement
enverra aussi plus de militaires
dans la région, en Lettonie,
pour renforcer son appui
à l'OTAN. Et ce n'est
qu'un début, dit Mélanie Joly.
MÉLANIE JOLY, ministre
des Affaires étrangères
- L'invasion a commencé.
Nous répondons donc
aujourd' la russie va
intensifier ses actions, plus
les actions du Canada et
de nos alliés vont
s'intensifier.
vernement fédéral
implore d'ailleurs
ses ressortissants
qui se trouvent encore
en Ukraine de rentrer au pays.
LIDIA WOLANSKYJ,
Canadienne en Ukraine
- Absolument non.
- Pourquoi pas?
- Non, je n'ai pas besoin de
partir.
- Un appel que n'entend pas
écouter Lidia Wolansky,
une Canadienne installée dans
l'ouest de l'État depuis 30 ans.
- J'ai pas de désir d'évacuer
l'Ukraine maintenant. Je ne sens
pas un danger direct.
J'ai espoir que les grands pays
comme l'Europe, les Américains,
les Canadiens, vont réagir assez
efficacement maintenant.
- Mais cet expert en sécurité
internationale doute que
les sanctions économiques
imposées jusqu'à maintenant
freinent l'ardeur
de Vladimir Poutine.
- Les sanctions ne sont pas tant
vues pour prévenir
le comportement russe
que pour le punir.
- Les pays occidentaux ont
promis d'ailleurs de punir
davantage la Russie si Moscou
intensifie son offensive.
La voie diplomatique
reste ouverte, répètent
les États-Unis, même si elle
semble de plus en plus fermée.
Ici Laurence Martin,
Radio-Canada, Ottawa.